avec Kevin ce qui s'est passé les
derniers mois bon déjà ça n'allait plus
du tout et quand il y a eu ce scandale
donc de tromperie c'était très compliqué
pour moi c'est comme si ta mère elle te
donnait un coup de poignard
je vais vous raconter un petit peu toute
ma vie mon démarrage quand j'étais
petite jusqu'à maintenant il s'en est
passé tellement des choses c'est vrai
que j'ai 26 ans et on va démarrer dès
l'enfance donc j'ai une merveilleuse
enfance du côté de ma maman c'est vrai
qu'elle a toujours pris soin de moi elle
m'a toujours éduqué correctement comme
il fallait c'est vrai que mon papa
j'étais très proche de lui mais pas
forcément il avait des complications
puisque il avait des travers assez
conséquents ouais il avait des travers
compliqués avec une addiction à l'alcool
et c'est vrai que ben j'ai subi beaucoup
ça malgré le fait d'avoir été très
entouré par la famille de ma maman ça
m'a ça m'a forcément affecté il y a eu
énormément de moments et de scènes qui
m'ont marqué à vie j'ai assisté à
beaucoup beaucoup de scènes choquantes
qui m'ont marqué forcément et quand j'ai
grandi au final je pense que comment
j'ai grandi ça a été beaucoup en
fonction de ce qui m'a manqué le fait
que mon père n'était pas présent donc
j'ai certainement fait beaucoup
d'erreurs à présent deux parce que je
pense que j'ai eu un manque d'affection
du côté masculin et de mon père et je
pense que c'est aussi pour ça que je
suis aussi maman poule avec ma fille et
à quel point je donne tout pour elle
parce que j'ai ressenti des fois des
choses difficiles dans ma vie et c'est
vrai que ce que j'ai ressenti j'ai
jamais envie qu'elle le ressentent donc
je suis toujours présente derrière elle
bon moi l'école et moi ça fait bon c'est
pas on est pas très meilleurs amis j'ai
été jusqu'à la coiffure donc en fait
j'ai travaillé jusqu'au collège après
j'ai fait un apprentissage en CAP
coiffure qui sait très bien passé parce
que moi dès que je fais quelque chose
c'est soit tout soit rien donc j'étais
une des meilleures dans la coiffure
d'ailleurs avant même de faire de la
télé ce que j'envisageais c'était
d'ouvrir des salons de coiffure voilà
j'ai toujours aimé ça et le problème
c'est que voilà moi je me donne à 100%
dans tout et à un moment donné j'ai été
un petit peu déçue de la manière dont je
travaillais ça me convenait plus je
faisais tout le temps les mêmes choses
matin midi et soir j'en avais un petit
peu marre à plusieurs reprises on
m'avait proposé des émissions télé à
chaque fois je refusais parce que
j'étais tellement bien dans mon boulot
et puis j'imaginais tellement mourir
plein un salon et tout que je suis
restée focus là-dessus et à un moment
donné je sais pas ça allait plus
sentimentalement j'avais une déception
j'en avais marre de travailler bah du
coup dans le lieu où j'étais parce que
ça se passait pas forcément très bien
avec les filles avec avec qui je bossais
donc je me suis dit finalement bah c'est
peut-être l'occasion c'est peut-être le
moment de changer d'air de partir dans
quelque chose que je ne connais pas dans
l'inconnu et tout de suite en fait ils
m'ont enfin ils m'ont contacté à travers
Facebook pour ce qui est de la
téléréalité et j'étais toute jeune parce
que j'avais 18 ans donc j'étais vraiment
toute jeune je connaissais pas du tout
je crois que j'avais vu quelques
épisodes des Marseillais encore mais je
me suis dit allez pourquoi pas il
voulait m'ont fait passer un casting sur
Marseille je me suis pointée au
rendez-vous et en fait j'ai parlé
librement comme là je parle d'ailleurs
voilà je pense qu'ils ont vu en moi
quelqu'un qui était très spontané moi je
suis beaucoup dans l'excédent tout donc
je suis une amoureuse de l'amour voilà
donc forcément j'étais un peu la
personne parfaite pour correspondre le
type de format donc ils sont dit celle
là elle va être parfaite elle va tomber
vite amoureuse ça va être un bordel bon
ça a été le cas mais voilà et du coup
j'ai été vite sélectionné et je suis
parti directement non c'était dans cette
première aventure des Marseillais en
Afrique du Sud je ne connaissais pas les
techniques pour être la candidate
parfaite ou pour comprendre tout ce qui
allait arriver à la suite de cette
aventure parce que moi je me laissais
vraiment porter hyper naturel je
réfléchissais pas à ce que j'allais
faire j'étais à fond à 100% ben dans ce
que je vivais j'étais trop heureuse
j'étais à l'autre bout du monde avec des
personnes que je connaissais pas des des
gens complètement fous et jobards qui
criait partout donc des fois ça allait
des fois ça allait un peu moins c'est
vrai qu'à l'époque il y avait pas les
placements de produits donc on gagne
notre vie qu'à travers la téléréalité
même tout ça avant on n'avait pas la
chance de pouvoir se le payer donc c'est
vrai que on se disait bah c'est génial
on parle l'autre bout du monde on est
avec nos amis on partage des bons
moments on est H24 avec des personnes
faut savoir que ce qu'on vit quand tu es
enfermé dans une maison avec des tonnes
de personnes tout est décuplé
c'est-à-dire tout ce que tu vas
ressentir va être x 1000
et forcément d'ailleurs je pense que ça
même ça laisse des séquelles au fur et à
mesure parce que à force forcément que
tu sors
différemment après une aventure comme ça
forcément déjà il y a pas les réseaux
sociaux donc forcément quand on faisait
une aventure en vrai on s'en foutait du
regard des autres on s'en foutait de
l'image qu'on pouvait renvoyer parce
qu'en vrai on passe à la télé mais il y
a des personnes qui allaient nous dire
ah tu as fait ça à cet épisode là et tu
te rends compte et ton image et c'est
vrai que c'était une pression en moins
parce qu'en fait on se laissait
quotidiennement porter par tout ce qui
se passait la télé d'aujourd'hui est
différente parce que justement ce côté
spontané qu'on avait à l'époque c'est à
dire que moi par exemple quand je suis
tombée amoureuse de Kevin avec mon
compagnon avec qui j'ai passé un long
moment j'étais vraiment amoureuse
j'étais pas là à raconter une fausse
histoire j'étais pas là à dire bah je
vais me mettre avec lui pour rester dans
la télé ou pour faire des vues ou pour
être connu je tombais pleinement
amoureuse de lui parce que c'était le
cas parce que j'étais vraiment
spontané là-dessus et je pense que ce
qui manque à l'heure d'aujourd'hui c'est
ce genre de comportement c'est tellement
comment ça la téléréalité qu'on en
devient plus naturel parce que on
connaît par cœur comment ça marche la
fiche technique alors que pourtant on
n'a aucun aucun scénario mais c'est
juste qu'on connaît ce qui marche on
sait ce que la télé veut de nous donc
c'est vrai que maintenant l'heure
d'aujourd'hui je trouve qu'il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes qui font
semblant qui raconte des fausses
histoires et c'est dommage parce que du
coup ça a tué la télé-réalité qui à
l'époque était géniale parce que les
gens apprécient regarder ça parce qu'il
se disaient ah là il se passe vraiment
quelque chose la personne ne pleure
parce qu'elle a vraiment de la peine ou
elle va s'embrouiller parce qu'il y a
vraiment eu une histoire derrière alors
qu'à l'heure d'aujourd'hui on sait même
plus si ce qui se passe c'est parce que
ben on lui a demandé derrière ou parce
que elle-même veut le faire pour
quelques vues je ne referai plus
télé-réalité parce que ça correspond
plus à la personne que je suis je l'ai
fait pendant des années je pense que
j'ai vécu mes meilleures années dans la
télé mais je pense qu'il y a un certain
moment il faut savoir lâcher ce genre de
choses pour partir sur d'autres
opportunités plus professionnelles quand
tu es connue et que ça c'est facile
parce que tu pars une fois ou deux fois
dans l'année parce que tu as l'habitude
de gagner facilement de l'argent bah en
vrai tu as envie de faire ça toute ta
vie forcément que tu t'accroches parce
que tu as envie de faire ça toute ta vie
c'est pas un métier fatiguant que malgré
tout même si tu as une charge énorme
mentalement bah tu pars une fois ou deux
dans l'année et après ça s'arrête là des
choses ont changé il faut évoluer avec
son temps on le voit d'ailleurs que
maintenant les influenceuses qui
marchent le plus ce sont les personnes
lambda c'est des filles qui qui se font
des tonnes et des tonnes de vues alors
qu'elles ont jamais fait aucune télé
elle sort de nulle part elle sort de
leur maison et au final elles sont plus
connues que des gens qui ont fait de la
télé pendant 10 ans c'est que bien
évidemment les choses elles ont évolué
elles ont changé et que le public il a
envie d'autre chose il faut avancer avec
son temps moi j'ai jamais eu la grosse
tête je suis toujours restée moi-même
j'ai pas la notion de ma popularité ou
pas c'est à dire moi quand je sors j'ai
une vie tellement simple je sors de
partout sur Marseille bah les gens ils
demandent des photos oui mais en fait je
vis ma vie je m'en fous je suis pas je
pense que ma vie à moi elle est restée
simple donc je je suis toujours resté
simple et puis je m'adapte tout le temps
la situation demain je gagne beaucoup
bah je vais profiter je vais faire
plaisir les gens que j'aime mais c'est
pas pour autant que je vais dire bah
regardez j'ai acheté une telle voiture
j'ai acheté tel montres j'ai enfin c'est
pas mon délire de montrer en fait je
suis plutôt dans dans ce côté discret et
je pense que c'est ça qui m'a sauvé
aussi de ce côté très visible très je
montre tout parce que c'est comme ça que
je fais rêver les gens non moi je fais
rêver les gens parce que justement j'ai
une vie classique que tout le monde
puisse se reconnaître
j'ai pas j'ai pas refait ma poitrine
j'ai pas refait mes lèvres j'ai pris un
refait en fait la personne qui regarde
son écran en regardant mes stories elle
se reconnaît j'ai une vie comme
n'importe qui pourrait avoir c'est à
dire j'emmène ma fille à l'école tous
les matins je m'occupe d'elle je lui
fais à manger quand elle rentre je fais
des activités avec elle je fais mes
courses une fois par semaine enfin je
veux dire j'ai une vie vraiment
classique quoi je vais pas mentir et
dire que non tout va bien bien
évidemment que quand tu fais 10 ans de
télé avec qui tu as vécu tes relations
amoureuses tes amitiés forcément quand
ça va pas tu as des séquelles c'est
évident je pense que dans ce métier de
lumière c'est très compliqué d'avoir des
gens des gens vraiment honnêtes envers
toi parce que beaucoup ont tendance à
vouloir faire du Best parce que
justement il se dit bah là à ce
moment-là au moins ça va faire des vues
au moins je veux on va faire parler de
moi et c'est ça qui est dommage parce
que du coup il y a plus rien qui est
vrai il y a plus rien qui est vraiment
sincère et je pense que les le public il
en a été fatigué de tout ça il a été
fatigué de déjà de voir ces personnes ne
plus être naturelle montrer que du luxe
en permanence je pense que c'est des
choses qu'à un moment donné tu peux pas
faire parce que ok d'accord l'excuse de
oui je peux tout filmer c'est parce que
je filme tout que je monte des choses de
luxe on n'est pas obligé de montrer un
sac d'une marque de luxe tu peux montrer
que tu vas aussi chez Zara et filmer que
ton truc Zara et ne pas montrer le reste
après faut savoir que ce genre de métier
c'est éphémère aussi c'est comme un
footballeur il a gagné 10 ans énormément
d'argent et puis après il va arrêter
d'en gagner donc
il faut aussi se dire qu'il y a
différents boulots des différentes
manières de gagner de l'argent c'est
vrai que nous on a eu de la chance parce
que il y en a très peu qui gagnent
beaucoup d'argent et qui sont choisis
vraiment qui deviennent des candidats
emblématiques ça a été notre cas à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui mais parce que ça
a été notre chance à nous j'ai rencontré
Kévin du coup on a pris du Sud
ou ben j'ai eu totalement un coup de
coeur pour lui on a vécu les montagnes
russes au fil des saisons des des
moments de tournage ensemble
parce que justement
un coup ça allait un coup ça allait pas
bon c'est un petit peu le le même
processus que si on était dans une vie
classique mais c'est vrai que ben voilà
on a subi quand même pas mal de choses
jusqu'à un moment donné où on a décidé
de se poser d'avoir une petite fille moi
ce que je voulais c'était oui tombe
amoureuse d'avoir une famille
voilà je suis une femme un peu de à
marier en quelque sorte parce que
j'adore recevoir j'adore faire plaisir
mon mari donc effectivement
ça collait pile poil et le fait que lui
aussi était sur la même longueur d'onde
on s'est dit ben ça y est c'est le
moment de se projeter vers un enfant et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a une
merveilleuse petite fille qui s'appelle
ruby on avait vécu des des jolies années
jusqu'à ben précédemment là récemment où
ça a été un changement de vie totale on
va dire avec Kevin ce qui s'est passé
les derniers mois bon déjà ça n'allait
plus du tout clairement on était on
prenait des virages complètement
différents que ce soit l'un et l'autre
et cette dernière année elle a été
radicale alors j'ai on a vécu aussi pas
mal de choses on a eu vécu des scandales
qui ont été difficiles qui ont affecté
forcément notre couple parce que ben
forcément que c'est compliqué moi je
parle jamais sur les réseaux de ma vie
privée parce que parce que j'aime garder
les choses pour moi mais j'ai vécu des
choses très compliquées très
traumatisantes dans ma vie et c'est vrai
que si t'as pas le mental déjà pour tu
tiens pas et quand il y a eu ce scandale
donc de tromperie c'était très compliqué
pour moi c'est comme si ta mère elle te
donnait un coup de poignard c'est c'est
une vraie trahison mais familiale c'est
à dire que pour moi quand on trompe une
personne qu'on a aimé avec qui tu
partages tout avec qui quand tu as des
enfants quand tu es marié pour moi c'est
la pire trahison alors je sais qu'il y a
plein de femmes et parce que j'en ai
discuté avec des tonnes de femmes qui me
disent ah ben moi par exemple j'aurais
accepté moi je répète accepté pour moi
la tromperie ça a fait partie beaucoup
de notre début de relation donc j'ai
toujours été traumatisé par ça ça a été
un ça a été très compliqué pour moi
parce que j'ai subi énormément c'est
trahison là j'y accepté de revenir vers
lui par amour parce que je n'arrivais
pas à l'oublier et je lui avais donc
expliqué bien sûr quand on allait avoir
un enfant que que voilà c'était soit en
se mettait ensemble et on faisait les
choses bien et on finissait notre vie
ensemble et enfin du moins on essayait
de se tirer le plus vers le haut
pour pour nous pour notre enfant ou soit
on arrêtait là on arrêtait de se côtoyer
c'est vrai que je lui en veux beaucoup
alors maintenant c'est passé parce que
effectivement voilà je suis bien d'être
séparé et franchement je suis tellement
posé dans ça n'allait tellement plus
avec lui que au final je me retrouve et
je me sens beaucoup mieux mais par
contre c'est vrai que ça a été un
chamboulement de vie et que c'était
assez traumatisant que du jour au
lendemain tu passes de Fanny à
célibataire à mère célibataire à devoir
encaisser pas mal de choses surtout
qu'il y a tout qui sort sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est sûr que c'est pas évident
et qu'il faut vraiment avoir un mental
un mental très fort donc effectivement
j'ai vécu des choses difficiles on s'est
séparé à cause de cette de cette
tromperie qui a été qui a été pour moi
maintenant avec le recul pour tout vous
dire je pense que j'en ai énormément
souffert mais je me sens libérée c'est à
dire que j'ai réussi à sortir d'une
relation sur laquelle j'étais incapable
au départ j'étais incapable parce que
j'étais dans cette relation très toxique
où je me disais je peux pas vivre sans
lui je l'aime c'est l'amour de ma vie
puis moi j'ai toujours voulu être finir
avec le père de mes enfants c'était pour
moi un schéma obligatoire parce que j'ai
tellement souffert quand j'étais petite
que pour moi c'était obligé d'avoir un
homme sur qui
avec qui je partage toute ma vie
forcément ça a été très difficile pour
moi de me dire voilà tu vas te séparer
quand j'ai entendu ce qui est arrivé bon
forcément je me suis écroulée parce que
je le souhaite à personne c'était des
conditions très difficiles parce qu'en
plus de ça c'était donc une fille qui
était la femme à son cousin donc que
j'avais côtoyé chez moi dans ma maison
et tout enfin c'était un délire quoi
c'est limite un film que tu te dis ça
existe que dans les films mais pas dans
une vraie vie mais au final avec le
recul je me dis que cette fille m'a
rendu service bizarrement alors que pour
moi j'arrive même pas à prononcer son
prénom je me dis en fait elle m'a autant
fait souffrir qu'elle a amélioré ma vie
parce que à présent j'ai souffert
effectivement je souffre du deuil que je
fais de lui et le fait que j'ai plus
cette vie de famille mes parents je me
sens soulagée de plus vivre dans cette
relation toxique et d'avoir quitté ça
parce que ça ne correspondait plus à ma
vie et je pense que c'est pas anodin de
toute façon je pense que la vie elle
fait rien sans rien donc maintenant je
prends sur moi c'est sûr que c'est pas
évident chaque jour forcément de
s'entendre parce qu'on a un enfant en
commun
j'ai dû vraiment essayer d'être le plus
la plus gentille possible malgré tout et
c'est ça qui est difficile que
maintenant ni repensant je me dis mais
je suis tellement heureuse d'avoir
quitté ce que j'ai mis des années à
quitter que maintenant en vrai mais fais
ce que tu veux c'était un mal pour un
bien même si j'ai souffert énormément et
que forcément la vie difficile pour se
remettre dans des changements et dans
des transformations différentes mais
c'était un mal pour Amiens je pense
qu'il y a des limites à ne pas franchir
il les a franchis donc maintenant et ben
voilà les décisions étaient prises et
chacun fait sa vie après on essaye de ce
que ça se passe au mieux pour notre
enfant parce que c'est c'est la priorité
c'est rubis donc il faut qu'elle se
sente bien et voilà j'ai pas de regret
je pense que j'ai vécu les choses telles
qu'il fallait que je les vive j'ai
apprécié mes années de télé même si
elles ont des fois été difficile je les
ai appréciées parce que ça a changé ma
vie et que on peut pas cracher dans la
soupe alors que en vrai on a tous été
très heureux de faire de la téléréalité
donc non j'ai passé les meilleures
années
auprès de des Marseillais mais je pense
qu'effectivement il faut évoluer avec
son temps et que petit à petit tu
grandis moi j'ai démarré j'avais 18 ans
j'en ai 26 je suis devenu maman
j'ai été plus posée et je j'ai envie de
d'une direction différente dans ma vie
donc je ne crache pas sur ce qui ce que
j'ai fait mais par contre c'est vrai que
ça ne me correspond plus j'essaye de
couper mon temps entre le rôle de maman
que j'ai et que j'adore faire et ce côté
professionnel parce que je sais que j'ai
la chance d'avoir une communauté qui est
présente qui est active pour moi qui
attend toujours que je leur propose
beaucoup de choses et c'est le cas donc
il va arriver plein de jolis chats je
peux pas vous en parler mais il va
arriver beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
bien sûr de partir sur quelque chose de
plus professionnel qui correspondent à
ma vie d'aujourd'hui que des cœurs je
suis célibataire voilà je pense que une
femme c'est un peu compliqué je pense
pas qu'elle refait sa vie aussi
facilement et puis c'est pas mon but
j'ai envie de profiter de la vie en
étant un peu seul c'est vrai que j'ai
jamais vécu en fait justement ce côté
femme célibataire puisqu'on a tellement
été tout le temps H24 ensemble depuis
des années que j'ai envie de prendre du
temps pour moi de profiter avec mes amis
de me poser de passer surtout ma
carrière en priorité et ce qui viendra
et ce qui arrivera arrivera on verra
plus tard